And he also wanted to
go to church every week,
and I'm like this too.
It's a better week if
you've been to church.
Nobody believes that anymore I guess.
I believe that.
That's good.
And I think Jack thought that.
Bobby became in the end sort of interested
in the Dorothy Day,
Catholic Worker Catholicism.
The radical concern about the poor.
But he was also trying to figure out
what was the religious motivation
behind somebody like Cesar Chavez?
What role does Catholicism
play in his getting up
in the morning and
leading a labor movement
in the California fields?
How did that move Dorothy Day living
down in the bowery of New York?
How did that move her?
He wanted to find a connection
between his religion
and his purpose.
He really wanted to figure
out life as he understood it.
I thought that was
something that got to me.
He's the genuine article.
I mean, he's not perfect obviously,
but I wasn't looking for that.